you know what i said the other day
what did you see the other day i was i
was grabbing an avocado to see if it was
ripe or not i was just like rubbing it
then i threw it back in there and i'm
like is that inappropriate
it's not appropriate i mean you're
supposed to you're supposed to [ __ ]
know if it's ripe or not i mean kovid
has
all this thing going on at us like
feeling some type of way about touching
[ __ ] how am i supposed to know if it's
ripe especially avocados you can't know
i agree but i think because of cove and
everyone's become so anal about hey
problems in proximity that just like me
touching it i look around just to see if
anyone sees me touching oh no start
rubbing them
i have to start rubbing you go ahead i
think cause an avocado you don't you
don't eat the outside at all right and
apple might be a different story washer
sheet but you generally wash it wash the
[ __ ] just just wash your stuff you know
what i mean
so
yeah
people are getting crazy about this what
was the better thing was the
alternative i want to check for avocados
oh well put it in my pocket i don't want
it but i can't put it back so i'm not
buying i'm not buying it that's true
yeah i don't think there's any other way
to tell if it's ripe or not i think
we'll have a cause of such a short
window before they're trashed yeah these
[ __ ] are like you got 10
minutes bro yeah yeah yeah 10 minutes
avocados are fickle as hell bro 10
minute window and then they age like
white women they just like so quick
there's a peak and then it just dies
[Laughter]
you know what they say white women age
like milk
he's like avocado
that prime is legit
oh my god
they're gonna hate you for this yeah
yeah yeah
see that's why you were
i allow white women with me to say [ __ ]
in bed so
they get some privileges
no you don't
anyways what's the next one
oh my god he said avocado age like white
woman god damn they're the white wine
emma fruits
that's a very good point
oh my god
if you have to assign races to each
fruit would you would you
rate a race to eat fruit yes
i feel like pears are asian for some
reason
i don't know they give me an asian
evidence
bears are asian
what's the shape you look at a pear
you're like some chinese [ __ ] right now
he's so chinese you said they aged like
white women let this man go chinese is
wild bro and pears aged pretty well you
could keep a pair for a while you know
until until when it ages it ages ages
quick that's right
you see excited
easy i am out of this
oh my god